you might think that the pull-up is as
simple an exercise as you can get this
is a basic bodyweight movement that
builds big lats and your biceps to a
slightly lesser extent in fact it's such
a common move that's often used as a
basic measure of strength and
fitness whilst this is all true the
pull-up can also actually do a whole lot
more it trains a whole lot more and with
a few subtle tweaks you can get all
sorts of additional benefits out of it
there's more to the pull-up than meets
the eye
[Music]
first of all the pull-up doesn't just
train the biceps in many ways actually
trains the biceps in a more functional
manner than exercises like the curl
especially if you use a supinated grip
which would make it a chin up and this
targets the biceps a little bit more and
the reason it's so valuable for the
biceps is because your biceps actually
are biarticular that means that they
span two different joints in this case
the elbow joint and the shoulder the
biceps therefore actually play a role in
both shoulder stabilization and flexion
so if you're just holding your arm still
and curling at the elbow and you're not
using the bicep to its fullest
of course the pull up is also great for
training the back and i don't just mean
the lats here i mean the rhomboids the
traps even the rear delts all these work
together to help retract the scapula and
pull your body up towards the bar
however if you're performing pull ups
without giving it any thought you're
probably not maximizing this benefit and
i'm going to show you why here so a lot
of people will perform a pull-up in a
very vertical manner simply grab the bar
and pull themselves straight up like
this
whilst that's fine it has its benefits
that we'll talk about in a moment it
doesn't maximize the involvement of
those additional muscles in the back and
if this is your primary tool for
training your back you could be getting
more out of this movement so what we
want you to do is to arch your back and
perform what are sometimes called arched
pull-ups here you're going to extend
your spine and even your legs to a
lesser extent so that you're essentially
looking like a a bridge then pull
yourself up leading with the chest and
the sternum rather than the chin the aim
here is to touch your chest onto the bar
or get it as close as you can so that
would look something like this
my bar actually isn't perfect for this
because the uh
these arms stick out and get a little
bit in the way so that's it right that's
the perfect pull-up that's how you
should be doing your pull-ups well no
that's not really the point and in fact
that's one of the things i try and rally
against on this channel in general
there's no one correct way to do a
movement and actually there are benefits
to not doing your pull-ups this way
first of all if you want to get those
benefits if you want to train the
scapular attractors you want to train
the rear delts you can do something
similar by using bodyweight rows which
many of you know are one of my favorite
exercises by far incorporate these into
your training and then you have a
horizontal body weight movement so you
can do a more vertical pull up and you
get the benefits of both
even a seated row machine anything like
that is going to give you those same
benefits
and you could argue that there's not a
huge amount of point in training
pull-ups with a more horizontal position
because one of the big benefits of the
pull-up is that it is a vertical pull
and it's one of very few vertical pull
movements that we do apart from the lat
pull-down
if you're doing vertical pushes like a
shoulder press which you probably should
be then you should be doing a vertical
pull as well to balance things out at
the same time
vertical pulling is useful for a bunch
of different things in particular
climbing if you want to climb over wall
if you want to do rock climbing you
don't have the option of arching your
spine and bringing all those different
muscles into play so you should be
learning to pull yourself up in a more
vertical position as well and in fact
there's a pull-up variation for this
which is called the tactical pull-up
when performing a tactical pull-up the
idea is pretty much the opposite instead
of arching the spine and getting into
extension you instead want to adopt a
hollow body position that means you're
going to be slightly protracting the
shoulder blades now you're going to be
tensing the rectus abdomini on the front
of the stomach and you're going to be
creating a concave position in the
opposite way engage the hip flexors get
your legs slightly pointed forwards
point the toes create tension throughout
the entire body then what you're going
to do is put your hands on top of the
bar so that your thumb is also on top of
the bar no gripping from underneath this
is important because if you are climbing
a wall then of course you can't grip
your thumb underneath and this prepares
you for that type of movement performing
pull ups in this position is perfect for
military personnel for rock climbers for
free runners whereas the arched one is
better for bodybuilders you want to
create back development or anyone trying
to improve their posture i recommend
that you combine both or a couple of
exercises that train all these different
things of course pull ups also great for
training with grip and if you want to
take a little bit further then you can
try using a crimp or a half crimp grip
like a rock climb and another variation
that's similar of the tactical pull-up
is to use a similar grip just your
fingers take your thumb completely off
the bar and this is so that if you ever
had to climb a wall or something holding
onto a torch or something in that hand
then you'd be able to do that keeping
your thumb free and you can even just
practice holding something in that hand
whilst performing pull-ups which is
quite a fun and unusual way to mix up
your pull-up training
conversely if you want to strengthen
your grip during the movement and
thereby increase the number of pull-ups
that you can perform then you might want
to consider wrapping your fingers
tightly over the bar and then using your
thumb underneath and lapping it on top
of your finger what this does is it
creates a closed loop you call your
thumb's opposing thumbs because they
create the most strength by opposing the
other digits and this wonderful change
can actually increase your max number of
pull-ups alternatively if you simply get
your fingers more on top of the bar more
like a false grip so that the finger
knuckles on top of the bar this can
actually increase activation of the lats
it's really interesting how just
changing the positions of your hands can
really alter a movement hand should
ideally be about shoulder width apart or
just slightly wider these bars are
basically right where i want to put my
hands unfortunately another question
that you might be asking is what the
ideal range of motion for your pull-ups
are and again the answer really depends
what your goals are for the pull-up so
if you want to increase your work
capacity and stimulate hypertrophy i
actually recommend using a slightly more
limited range of motion this is going to
allow you to perform more repetitions
it's going to prevent the muscle from
relaxing causing blood to pull there
increasing the build up of metabolites
which can contribute to hypertrophy and
at the same time it's going to make for
a much faster and more explosive and
dynamic exercise which is going to get
your heart rate up thereby building
muscle and at the same time burning some
calories high high repetition body
weight training is an overlooked and
underutilized training method which is
great for just packing on size and
building a kind of strength endurance
which is really functional and useful
out there in the real world and if
you're worried about losing some
strength by not performing the full
range of motion then i ask you when
would you ever pull something from up
high and intentionally completely raise
your arm overhead you wouldn't you'd
always start with your arms about here
and pull from there
what we do want is that mobility whether
it's for performing handstands or
anything else and in that case what you
can do is you can completely relax and
lower yourself to the very bottom of the
pull-up in between each repetition and
even allow your shoulders to slightly
raise up like this
this is essentially a dead hang if you
hang like this just for minutes at a
time it's a fantastic way to open up the
shoulders increase mobility and even to
decompress the spine it can be once
again fantastic for undoing some of the
damage that we cause by being in a
hunched position
all day normally in dead hangs you just
hang there for a minute or so but if
you're performing pull ups if you slowly
lower yourself into that same position
hang for a moment and then pull yourself
back up you're completely removing any
momentum any stretch reflex so you're
now having to engage a lot more strength
from cold each time
don't drop hard at that position this
can cause pain and injury and at the
same time if you're new to training or
if you're not that confident in your
shoulder strength and stability then you
might want to build up to this and
instead you can just place one foot
gently on the floor or two feet gently
on the floor to take off a little bit of
that pressure whilst you're in that
position i've heard it said that getting
to this position can actually increase
your risk of shoulder impingement but
according to research by one john kirsch
it's actually the opposite this position
could actually open up the shoulders and
even slightly move their chromium to
ease any impingement pain you might have
and to prevent it from happening in the
first place
and finally pull ups of course serve as
a perfect jumping off point for a whole
range of cool variations particularly
plyometric movements things that involve
manipulating your body weight in the air
like i say this is a fantastic tool for
building your strength to weight ratio
if you're a rock climber if you're a
circus performer if you're a free runner
then being able to lift your body weight
with ease is a really important skill
and at the same time it can just look
fantastic like it's gravity-defying
and if you look at videos from the likes
of bar stars and those guys you'll see
that some really truly incredible stuff
is possible so as i said there's much
more to the humble pull-up than meets
the eye let me know if i missed anything
in the comments down below thank you so
much for watching this video guys if you
like this kind of training that looks
beyond the surface level and aims to
improve all-round performance as well as
just strength and size then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training you'll find a
link to that description down below by
the way this is my first video back from
paternity leave so from bitrusty then i
apologize i am working on the batman
training for 2022 as well as a bunch of
other really cool stuff it's a little
bit delayed just because i took a whole
month off but yeah we're back full steam
ahead now got some really exciting
things planned so if you want to see
that then please subscribe and hit the
bell button to get notifications either
way thank you so much i'll see you next
time
bye for now